[Musique]
voilà bien des années que le jardin de
l'état est la référence des moments
plaisir pendant les vacances
ici les rayons du soleil coupe les
branches d'une végétation accueillante
un cadre idéal pour lucie qu'est venu
faire ses ateliers à la bibliothèque
départementale en famille à moi j'aime
beaucoup parce que j'aime beaucoup le
scrapbooking enfin les actes les
ateliers créatifs parce qu'on a
travaillé après c'est moi je trouve que
c'est très beau après ce qu'on fait
partiront liv est une opération
nationale qui déplace les structures au
plus proche des lecteurs mais à la
bibliothèque départementale
seul un lieu toute l'année car ça fait
partie de nos missions la bibliothèque
de proposer des animations hors les murs
d'aller vers les publics les plus
éloignés de la culture
nous allons à l'hôpital nous allons au
sein des familles qui ont quelques
difficultés avec le livre nous allons
bien sûr dans les jardins nous sommes
présents lors de la manifestation a b d
e vraiment sortir de notre bibliothèque
et est surtout le département c'est une
volonté que l'on que l'on a juste
derrière l'atelier de loisirs créatifs
offre un cadre idéal des changes entre
parents et enfants
par hasard et finissant parti tout de
suite est plus grande et pas bien sûr le
petit frère comme à la maison ici on
passe du temps ensemble et qui en même
temps ils apprennent s'exprime si donner
envie de lire et l objectif cette
opération tout simple semble fonctionner
pour ces enfants qui le temps d'une
après midi se sont évadés dans un livre
[Musique]